licking the spoon is the best part of
baking cookies but it's a bad idea
because eating raw cookie dough really
can make you sick and not just because
it contains raw eggs in 2009 over 77
people across 30 states got food
poisoning after eating prepackaged raw
cookie dough many experienced vomiting
and bloody diarrhea and some had severe
kidney damage in the end nestle had to
recall 3.6 million packages of it's
refrigerated cookie dough and in 2016
another group got sick after eating raw
homemade cookie dough made from General
Mills products but despite what you'd
expect but culprit wasn't Salmonella in
the eggs it was a Shiga toxin-producing
e.coli in the flour the same type that
sometimes finds its way into romaine
lettuce and hamburger meat in fact the
CDC estimates it's responsible for 265
thousand illnesses 3600 hospitalizations
and 30 deaths in the United States every
year now normally ecoli likes to bunker
down in moist places that's why
scientists were surprised when it turned
up in flour and even today it's a
mystery as to how the e.coli got there
in the first place or how it survived in
the flowers dry environment the problem
is that the bacteria could have
infiltrated the flour during any step of
the manufacturing process it might have
snuck onto the wheat from animal poop or
jump to the flour from a contaminated
processing equipment
there's really no way to know for sure
now just to be clear
although flour was the culprit in this
case raw eggs can still be just as
dangerous in fact the FDA estimates that
every year contaminated eggs cost
seventy nine thousand foodborne
illnesses and 30 deaths in the United
States with that in mind the CDC warns
against eating any raw cookie dough but
there's good news
although yes there's a risk your cookie
dough is contaminated it's a pretty
minimal one many bakers for example
taste tests all the time no worse for
wear
plus a study found that over half of
college students ate unbaked cookie
dough and they live to tell the tale
even better the risk is lower today than
ever before
at least when it comes to store-bought
varieties because after the 2009
outbreak companies like Nestle in
Pillsbury have started including
heat-treated flour and pasteurized eggs
in their dough by heating flour to 71
degrees Celsius you kill off any e.coli
and the pasteurization process heats
eggs just enough to kill off bacteria
without cooking the egg he treated flour
and pasteurized eggs also explain why
the sort of cookie dough you find an ice
cream is harmless but if you insist on
making your chocolate chip cookies from
scratch there is a DIY way to sterilize
your own ingredients bake the cookie
it'll still taste good